bon alors lis on va faire une interview
maintenant on va baisser la lumière à
bayonne - je dois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
voilà c'est ma joie
il ya le sampler aussi tiens je vais
vous mettre
le mouv revenu à la croisière s'amuse
ça j'adore quand je suis à mon sport mon
prof de gym quand je fais mon sport il
mais ça sinon jamais moi
bon alors les eaux vous avez dit vous
avez déclaré
c'est bizarre j'ai toujours été une
femme seule j'étais accompagné
finalement très peu de temps et j'ai eu
mes enfants avec des hommes différents
ma célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez et étudier pas été lire ou si
vous étiez resté wanda est ce que vous
auriez moins de problèmes avec les
hommes oui pourquoi
parce que c'est très difficile de se
retrouver à un moment donné
comme étant monsieur lio et moi je n'ai
entendu ça des gens qui venaient qui
présentait mais mes hommes comme
monsieur lio est en fait moi je trouvais
c'était ridicule de la part des autres
mais eux petit à petit trouvé ridicule
de ma part des trios mais c'était
dommage parce que je l'étais avant je ne
pouvais pas arrêter tout d'un coup
c'était maintenant c'est comme une
seconde nature lio et ça a posé des
problèmes mais ça pose des problèmes je
mets un problème de gagner plus que son
âme aussi bon alors c'est vrai alors
donc voila moi j'ai fait le compte quand
même là lieu lui dire d'abord c'est
marrant on trouve normal par contre de
dieu là dans ma chambre le monde s'en
fout un peu bouché
on s'est suffisamment chamailler sur des
plateaux pour que je puisse vous faire
un compliment sincère je vous trouve
très belle en ce moment là présentement
des âmes ainsi très joli vous êtes bien
une belle robe vous êtes des belles nat
et j'adore les brunes et vous avez du
rouge à lèvres un peu rouge ça ça me
plait sa mère béatrice je te le dis si
tu pouvais mettre le même genre de rouge
à lèvres que liu ça me ferait plaisir
bon allez maintenant a
vraiment raison
les du sud lui c'est normal une
portugaise c'est un ça le fait un
renouveau avec ortega show la
parfaite réseau il est chaud je te dis
pas bonjour
j'ai compté les sommes
avancées pas encore gloria lasso mais
quand même c'est sur la route 1
c'est-à-dire il ya eu d'abord votre
premier
duval il faut bien prendre le parolier
qu'on adore tous ben voilà que j'ai 13
ans et demi oui
ensuite il ya eu estévenens notre ami
est et ben qui vous avez qui vous veut
du bien oui ensuite j'ai eu patrick
alexis ou avec qui vous a eu deux
enfants igor et
général d'années déjà 1 2 3 oui non
attendez
non maintenant 1 2 3 4 zad le dernier en
date avec qui vous avez les jumelles
voient la barre d'un coup photo n'est
pas beaucoup mais non ah bon mais je
suis vieux juillet moitié des enfants à
chaque fois 5 en format n'ont ainsi pas
eu d'ailleurs lio avait deux familles
c'est vrai bio c'est je le sais moi je
vous ai vue elle était nue bia sur les
plateaux il ya aux bains douches alors
vous avez déclaré mon ami hugo pratt
m'avait pourtant conseillé de ne pas
tuer le désirent dans ce milieu avides
de chair fraîche personne ne veut d'une
fille avec cinq gosses aux basques vous
pensez que ça vous handicape aujourd'hui
tous ces enfants mois 6 mois sam
handicap un sujet
mikros par
mouassa m'handicape pas au contraire
dans ma vie de femme c'est quelque chose
de génial mais ça ça handicape dans mon
travail mais oui bien sûr sam handicap
dans mon travail parce que c'est c'est
pas de trouver des gens en général les
femmes veulent bien travaillé avec moi
mais derrière une femme réalisatrice il
ya toujours un homme producteurs et
l'homme producteur lui n'a pas envie
d'une artiste à problèmes entre
guillemets c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
pourrait éventuellement lui refuse et
lui donner la 200e heures
supplémentaires gratos puisque c'est
maintenant ce qu'on vous demande moi
depuis que j'ai commencé à tourner mes
cachets ont été divisés par 3 voire 4
toujours soi disant pour des problèmes
de cinéma français qui ne marche pas
mais j'ai toujours vu les producteurs
avec la même des mw et les mêmes
costumes cheroutre donc donc vous voulez
je trouve que c'est comme un nouvel ex
esclavagisme parce que comme on manque
de boulot c'est difficile pour tout le
monde donc on commence à dire aux
techniciens faut diviser vos prix et
puis si c'est pas vous tuer
voilà et donc ça c'est effectivement et
donc qu'il ya autre chose qui joue c'est
quand tout d'un coup des producteurs ont
le choix entre lio est une autre une
autre brune pas trop grosse ils vont
prendre peut-être l'autre brune joli
mais qui a pas cinq enfants et moi je
vais être éliminés sur ce critère
immédiatement oui mais c'est la vérité
je vais pas vraiment qu'alonso est pas
là dites moi où elle montre tous les cas
pour une fille qui a eu cinq enfants
c'est vachement bien
pour une fille kidnappée je savais qu'en
france mais comment je vais pas cinq
enfants ça serait énorme pour une fille
qui a eu cinq enfants je me sens bien
j'ai une presque 40 ans c'est vrai
comment vous faites je baise
non mais vraiment tout seul me
connaissez je vais les commandes
enregistrent alors vous vous disiez donc
là vous avez des problèmes avec votre
jules actuelle et pourtant vous disiez
je crois que j'ai trouvé ce que je
cherchais je suis une butineuse il me
faut un vrai appel pour m'arrêter avec
lui il ya eu une vraie osmose comment ça
se fait que ce soit terminé aussi mal
après cette vraie osmose ah mais ça je
me fais toujours la question que je
continue à me poser qui me pose c'est
que des sacrés problèmes
je ne sais pas
toujours cette question quand ça se
termine mais c'est pas non
vous aviez l'air d'être tellement
d'avoir enfin trouvé mais je suis très
amoureuse de lui toujours oui mais je ne
veux plus jamais vivre avec lui vous
allez vous revoir quand même on n'a pas
le droit bon vous êtes un peu disputées
vont pas là pour dire ça donc il a quand
même pris deux mois ferme un oui oui oui
mais moi j'ai pris un et cassé ouais
ouais d'accord vous ne vous êtes pas
porter visite j'ai pas porté plainte par
vengeance vais quand même un peu porter
plainte si l'on n'a pas pris deux mois
ferme géante est parce que quand on
porte plainte c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'autre solution quand on essaie de
régler des problèmes
comme on peut avec ses moyens mais qu'à
un moment donné on va d'échec en échec
et de violent sans violence eh bien on
s'en réfère à la justice c'est pas que
je trouve ça formidable mais c'est que
je n'avais pas d'autre solution la
justice représente le père
c'est une autorité à laquelle on s'en
remet quand on reconnaît notre échec
notre échec à nous de résoudre le
problème voilà mieux vous avez dit que
vous jugiez la sanction un peu sévère là
les six mois à faire les six mois de
prison jamais dit ça je ne je ne suis
pas a priori pour la prison parce que je
trouve que ce n'est pas là qu'on résout
les problèmes mais
mais les deux mois ferme n'était qu'une
partie de la sentence et moi j'avais
besoin de protection et gelé obtenus et
la justice a fait des grands pas pour
les femmes battues il fallait qu'elle
les fasse parce qu'on est vraiment seul
dans ces cas là et surtout vous êtes
toujours coupable mois la plupart des
hommes qui m'ont parlé depuis n'ont pas
du tout le sentiment de s'adresser à une
victime mais c'est comme les femmes
victimes d'un violent c'est que je les
bien cherché comme en plus le monde sait
que c'est un sale caractère on se dit
que vraiment j'ai dû torturé ce pauvre
homme c'est quand même moi qui avait le
nez cassé et le une entorse cervicale et
quatre vertèbres déplacées qu'on a dû
remettre le les folies bergères et que
ça a été terrible et que je m'en remets
toujours pas moi en tout cas sûr ça ne
se voit pas et sur scène ça se voit pas
mais ça c'est la magie du spectacle
monsieur sur scène oui alors vous
flippez un peu sur votre âge jusque
quand on vous voit on a du mal à
comprendre franchement ou dit liu c'est
pas moi je la met en scène tous les
jours elles existent palio j'ai fait un
sale coup à lier aux gésiers le messager
nous disait yahia il ya dix ans déjà de
ça parce que c'est vrai lyon était la
représentation de l'adolescence elle
avait entre 12 et 14 ans quand je les
choisis c'était mon âge à l'époque dans
une bd de de jean claude forest et elle
était le symbole de l'adolescente oui et
c'est vrai que je ne suis plus le
symbole de l'adolescente avec cinq
enfants suspectés
six adolescentes à 50 ans et au ghana
oui est-ce que tu as presque vous je ne
critique pas le ghana je tiens à le dire
je veux pas d'histoires je ne critique
pas gala est-ce que vous avez vous dit
j'ai du mal à me voir vieillir j'ai la
mécanique s'affaiblit ce n'est jamais
très agréable
oui c'est vrai et c'est jamais très
agréable de devoir les heureux les
regards des hommes toujours attiré par
la jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante mais vous êtes une femme dans
la plénitude la wii non il faut pas
flipper lalliot n'ont peut-être cesser
c'est comme ça c'est sans doute une
étape obligée du succès très jeune avec
un personnage de lolita effectivement
banana split et tout ça mais quand on
vous voit là écouter thierry moi je
crois une chose je crois que on se voit
énormément dans le regard que l'homme
que vous aimez portent sur vous et je
crois que quand le regard qu'on reçoit
est quelque chose qui vous a faibli qui
qui vous remet tellement en question et
sur des choses qui sans doute sont
ridicules moi je trouve que c'est une
perte d'énergie totale mais la vérité
que ça moi sa marque il ya des choses
qui m'ont marqué c'est vrai que je me
regarde plus dans la glace avec la même
le même la même désinvolture disons
parce que moi je ne me suis jamais
regarder dans la glace avec attention
j'étais désinvolte et je la perds au
port et c'est une peur qui vient alors
je me demande d'y tourner très vite mais
je crois que je crois que c'est sale
tout simplement je crois qu'on ne
vieillit jamais quand les gens vivent
ces gens là devraient voilà moi je peux
vous dire parce que j'ai bien plus âgée
que vous problème c'est que dans la tête
on vit pas vraiment mais le corps vie et
puis après les gens les gens n'y croient
pas quand on dit ça on vous dit quand
même j'ai hâte d'être une vieille dame
indigne je vais te passer le cap de
l'antre 2 jamais mais avant le contre
on y voit un prêt c'est vrai qu'on a
envie à un moment de se dire ouais
rafinha un moment on se dit la
vieillesse il faut que ça serve à ne
plus tarder à voir la faute de rien
au moins cet avantage là c'est ça et de
pouvoir faire plein de conneries et puis
personne nous ne venions vous dire
quelle conne ça c'est génial ça sert en
quatre ans avec l'albanie merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
zinal habitudes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu